hi everyone welcome again to our PI data
event I'm Patricia Schuster one of the
co-organizers and our other coordinates
is our Gershon law and ben's island and
today we are welcoming midi can Muck so
before I introduce MIDI Ken I'm gonna go
through a few housekeeping items for the
curries
so our this group is sponsored by a few
different organizations num focus
sponsors our meetup group TD Ameritrade
provides us with the space together and
Midas pays for the dinner and so if you
know people from these organizations or
if you see them please say thank you for
funding our organization a few important
points emergency exit there is an
emergency exit right here if we need it
we're always looking for feedback on the
organization so if you have any thoughts
please share them either with us
directly or through our Twitter account
or through the gmail account listed here
and then we're in our borrowed space so
please clean up after yourself so the
way we do questions here is please hold
your questions until the end of midian
presentation unless they're very quick
please phrase your question in the form
of question and keep your questions to
30 seconds or less and avoid long
statements or monologues and remember
that we will have plenty of time for
open discussion after the Q&A now I will
read our code of conduct my data is
dedicated to providing a ver a sment
free meeting experience for everyone
regardless of gender sexual orientation
gender identity and expression
disability physical appearance body size
race or religion we do not tolerate
harassment of meeting participants in
any form all communication should be
appropriate for a professional audience
including people of many different
backgrounds sexual language and imagery
is not appropriate for any of our meet
up events be kind to others do not
insult or put down other attendees
behave professionally remember that
harassment and sexist racist or
exclusionary jokes are not appropriate
for Paideia attendees violating these
rules may be asked to leave the meetup
at the sole discretion of the meetup or
organizers thank you for helping make
this a welcoming friendly
for all so now we'd like to do a quick
icebreaker so you can meet the people
around you today's icebreaker is
courtesy sweetie good so please turn to
your neighbor and introduce yourself and
tell them a weird animal Pat yeah
according to their animals which have
transient penises that only appear when
they need to use them and then they
disappear oh wow convenient I didn't
know all right so so we also like to do
it this month in data science so today
we wanted to feature a piece that was
written by Erik Olson at stitch fix and
it's healthy where the data science pin
Factory the power of the full stack data
science generalist and the perils of
division of labor through function and
it's a very interesting piece arguing
that there's a lot of value in being a
data scientist who can do all all the
different pieces of the puzzle rather
than splitting the entire problem of
into different steps and sending each
step off to a different person and any
he visits a number of different aspects
of that I also want to mention our next
event is on April 10 okay Julia signal
who will be speaking on visualizing and
analyzing earth science data using PI
thes and PI data also there is a
conference coming up called not another
big data conference here in Ann Arbor
May 10th and 11th posted by Cass
okay are there any other community
announcements before we begin the talk
anyone looking for a job or looking to
hire at their company that they want to
make everyone aware these positions
[Music]
right Cody okay
excellent so afresh masters graduate
Python coding skills looking for a job
so if anyone's interested you can
connect after the talk can I say one
thing - welcome back to everybody this
is our two-year anniversary so okay so
now we will turn things over to MIDI ken
Medivh in monkeys at Osaka in the data
exploration lab at the National Center
for supercomputing applications at
University of Illinois urbana-champaign
Mindy can received her PhD from the
University of California Berkeley in
nuclear engineering and today she will
be talking about YT which is an
open-source data visualization package
for mesh and point based data so take it
away okay
yes so thank you for the wonderful
introduction Trisha um my name is Medici
and as she said afterwards if you'd like
to talk to me you can ask my name again
I know it's not the easiest name to
remember so that's fine don't worry
about it today I'm gonna be talking a
little bit about YT which is a package
that Trisha mentioned that's open source
for visualizing generally volumetric
data but I'm also going to be talking
about what we're doing to make YT
interactive and what solutions we have
taken in the YT community to try and
make it so we can make science and data
more accessible from many different
pathways so before I go too deep into YT
I wanted to say a little bit more about
myself so Tricia gave a great
introduction I'm mentioning my PhD and
nuclear engineering from UC Berkeley my
work primarily in my PhD was to
visualize no was to simulate radiation
transport through space and there were
there are visualization tools that are
very effective for visualizing the data
that I was using but there wasn't a lot
of open source packages available and so
I really wanted to make sure that as I
went on into my postdoc that I had the
ability to visualize my data however I
wanted
and with as much fidelity as I want to
do my work also for my PhD was done at
Oak Ridge National Lab and as a member
of the Berkeley Institute for data
science now I'm at my postdoc at the
University of Illinois at
urbana-champaign at the National Center
for supercomputing applications and I
work in a group called the data
exploration lab some members of the data
exploration rabb are core developers of
YT but the YT community is very broad
and international we have developers all
over the world and just a few of us
exist in the data exploration lab and in
general the data exploration lab is
about making data accessible in many
different ways whether that means
transparent through open science or by
making tools for visualization and data
analysis I also am very active in
various software communities I am a
member of the carpenters community I'm a
software carpentry instructor and a data
carpentry instructor I'm also the
maintainer of the of the get novice
lesson for software carpentry so if any
of you are really big get aficionados
come talk to me because I'm a big fan
and last this last logo here is the logo
for the num focus Committee for
diversity inclusion in scientific
computing and I'm on this committee I'm
very proud of the work that we do the
subcommittee I'm on actually works with
doing assessments of diversity and
inclusion and also we maintain the
discover cookbook which is a series of
tips to make events more accessible and
inclusive and so if you want to go here
we have lots of different tips there's
high impact high effort high impact low
effort and so we try to categorize
things to make it easy for different
events I also am very active in the Syfy
community if any of you are going to
scifi the summer I would love to see you
I will be there and I also am a core
developer of YT which lives in the
scientific Python ecosystem ok so now
I've given you this super long
introduction we can move into YT the
exciting part I'm just going to give you
a very
brief introduction to whitey and I'll
give you the link to the slides
afterwards so if you're really
interested in some of the stuff that you
see though these are links that lead to
the project website and the repository
and there's a lot of really great
documentation on all of the different
types of plots that you're going to see
today so in general what whitey does is
takes data from all different types of
visualization packages so these are just
some of the ones that we've that we can
pull ingest data in we pull it in
based on bespoke custom front-ends that
exist for each one of them because each
data visually data simulation package
that you might use outputs data in a
different way it might be on a regular
structured mesh it might output point
wise data and so we have to be able to
accept data from many different formats
because you can have volumetric data in
many accessible for many different
places so we ingest that into YT and we
put it into custom YT data objects and
then we can output that into different
visualizations or different analyses so
we can filter data we can get different
you know parameters that the that YT can
calculate that might be interesting to
you
YT was born in the astronomy and
astrophysics ecosystem so much of what
YT and you're gonna see today is based
on astronomy and astrophysics data but
we are actively trying to move into like
the broader scientific community and so
I'll kind of mention our efforts there
as I go through in this talk a little
bit more I mentioned that we have uh we
have to accept data in many different
types and volumetric data can exist in
in sort of different ways so we can pull
in data from octave ace meshes which is
data that's like refined and different
types of octants and you refine more and
more based on some parameter that's
interesting so if you see like a density
gradient in your simulation that you
think might have interesting physics the
mess will refine in that octant but only
in that place so that way you can refine
in areas that are important and have a
coarse mesh and
more unimportant areas we also can
accept data from structured regular
meshes these are things that like a lot
of nuclear engineering simulation
packages use structured regular meshes
it's just like a typical sort of you
know regular mesh where you might have
something in X a mesh an X and a mesh
and Y and it's the same for all x and y
then we have unstructured meshes this is
something that you might see in like a
CFD simulation or something like that
something that can go around round
objects often is an unstructured mesh
and then also particle data and so we've
been actively trying to make YT except
all these different types of volumetric
data and that's also challenging because
each one of them may look different in a
YT data structure and so as we move
forward into more domains this is
something that we actively have to be
cognizant of as we develop more we also
have a variety of visualization types
and you'll see some of these as we go
through we can slice in the domain in
whatever ordinate you want so X Y or Z
we could also do projection plots so you
can take you might want you might have a
plot in x and y and it integrates
through all of Z that would be a
projection plot a profile plot is
something in 2d that you might get an
average of something over one of your
dimensions and a phase plot is another
version of that and then we can also do
3d surfaces and Isak contours so if you
want to know about like some version of
density in your like where the density
and some part of your simulation is like
if you want this constant density you
can get the Issac contour of that
density and we also have supporting
analysis routines I mentioned before
that we don't just do visualization we
can do analysis so we can get derived
field so you might have a field of mass
and you might have a field of velocity
and we can make derive field of a
momentum because we have the mass in the
velocity fields we can do clump finding
which involves looking at like you know
you can choose something along density
and you can find the clump of where
those densities exist we can filter data
so we can filter data below or above a
certain parameter
if you're interested in that and then
also do profiles and histograms so I
mentioned that the project website is
really good at showing examples of this
I didn't actually want to like read put
them in here so we can see some of these
so you can see what a projection plot
looks like through the domain so this is
a slice of our sample data through Y
with density we can also look at what a
slice plot looks like with the same data
and you can see it like smoothes out as
you do this integral through space we
can also do interactions so this doesn't
actually have the interaction but we we
do have a volume interactive rendering
that is available but today I'm not
going to talk too much about that okay
we also have oh I think that there we go
so this is an example of something that
we might do with YT this is one of my
collaborators one of the other
developers of YT Nathan goldbam he did a
large simulation of a formation of a
galaxy in space and this is several
terabytes of data that he had to process
and this is a galaxy formation driven by
many different physics including star
formation and self-gravity and you can
see that there's many so first of all
there's many frames here you have to
process a lot of data this is also
projecting through density so we might
have so you might have something that so
you might have to collapse all your data
through the Z ordinate with density and
then process each time step and so you
can YT has the ability to process lots
and lots of data at a time but so also
YT can output data to different
extension packages so you just saw a
regular plot from YT with Nathan's data
this next video is using YT to output to
something called Houdini which is a
visual effects software that's like
volumetric and the day the NCSA has a
group called the advantage ization lab
which makes out outreach videos for
scientists and based on scientific data
and so
with Houdini and whitey knee which is
our extension package that connects
whitey and Houdini we can take
scientific data give it to artists and
then these artists can render it and
make it beautiful for science outreach
and so you can see this is the formation
of the same data ya know so whitey is
doing the post-processing of this data
so that I don't remember exactly which
software Nathan used to simulate that
it's doing the display right it's
processing the data afterwards so you
get like all of the physics and stuff
from some simulation code that you use
and then you can use whitey to
post-process that yeah exactly so we
have many whitey extension packages and
whitey knee is one of them you can see
this great logo which has the martini
but there's also some that we output to
make synthetic observation data so
there's x-ray data and things like that
and that's what some of these other ones
do if you're interested these are all
linked also so in the presentation later
you can look through that so I've kind
of talked I've given you a very brief
overview of all the features of whitey
and not all of them but like you know
some important ones that may be
interesting to you as we move forward in
whitey we really want to expand
applicability of whitey to other domains
and so we're gonna make a domain contact
system many things that are left over in
whitey are relevant to astrophysics and
astronomy but maybe aren't super
relevant to a nuclear engineer or
geologist or a climate scientist I don't
know what the Hubble constant is maybe
somebody else can tell me so we're
trying to isolate and modular eyes
whitey to make it more applicable to
different domains and so as we modular
eyes it will have analysis packages that
are unique to each domain that whitey is
building support for we also to make
some paths traversal and non-local
analysis in a symbolic field system and
through eat what each of these mean in a
second so in the domain context we're
targeting several fields so first
weather and climate and on the right
here this is a simulation of the
formation of a tornado done from
somebody at the University of Wisconsin
we're also I'm targeting oceanography
and hydrology and this is I think it's
so it's a simulation of ocean currents
off the coast of Massachusetts so you
can see Massachusetts is in the white
space here I always miss it
so also whole earth size biography and
tomography this is an image of the
seismic waves after the Tohoku
earthquake which created Fukushima and
so that like started the meltdown and
stuff like that and so this is a whole
or simulation of the Ricochet of seismic
waves through the earth and also
observational astronomy so we have all
these simulation packages but also
observational data is still
multi-dimensional in space so we'd like
to make it applicable to observational
astronomy nuclear engineering as you can
imagine I have some expertise there and
also neuroscience and so we want to be
able to read in MRI and x-ray data and
so all these images actually have been
created with YT but these are very
cutting-edge not in released versions of
YT yet I want to give you an example of
some other things we've done so I built
in some support for Geographic
projections so we can use this climate
data and weather data and project it
depending on what types of maps or
projections were interested in so this
is a global weather simulation I
downloaded the data from NASA with an
orthographic projection and then I did
the same image with a Robinson
projection and this is for I think
August 22nd 2018 so this is an entire
days worth of weather and I think it's
the air density No yeah the axis says
that we also want to make some so we're
also we have an open pull request for a
CF compliant front end which is nuts EDF
which is a standard data format for
climate and weather
and so these are some examples of data
that have been pulled in from radar
simulations and so we have three
different variations of this radar data
both projected and sliced through the
simulation and also I mentioned medical
imaging and these are something done by
somebody in our group named Sam walk out
and she has been working on building in
support for MRI data and so we can see
slices and also this is an average
through the entire skull on the far left
hand side over here and this is I asked
her why this data is missing here and
apparently the eyes are still important
in images like this and so it's to
preserve the patient's privacy so yeah
today I learned so also we want to do
path traversal and non-local analysis so
we can slice through X or Y or Z and we
can also do an arbitrary vector through
space but it would be interesting to
look at how data and our domain changes
given an arbitrarily defined path and so
we're building in support to be able to
do that to traverse at any point any
random points through our data and get
those get whatever the data points are
that we're interested in also we want to
revise our field systems I mentioned
that we can make these derived fields
based on like mass and velocity but
we're restructuring the field system to
be based on their base units and so you
can detect whatever available fields you
can create from it based on its units
and the unit system so YT is great and
it can do lots of different things and
it also is really really good for making
publication quality plots and data
visualization interactively
interactivity complement one another we
as we like look through our data we
might have a very large simulation and
there might be a point in our data that
is very interesting to us but we don't
know where it is yet right and so we
need to do either analysis on that data
to find where those interesting points
are and usually we need to have
interactivity to browse through that
right like we might be able to say okay
whereas like the highest temperature
region and my simulation or whereas the
lowest density region but it might be a
little bit more complicated than that
so this is an example of somebody in our
group's work not in our group at NCSA
but somebody who works on the YT project
Britain Smith and he simulated the
formation of a population two-star which
is a second-generation
star it has interesting some interesting
slightly light elements mostly light
elements and on the he made this with
both using YT and also he did a lot of
customization of the plots with
matplotlib and so this is a huge
simulation several terabytes of data and
he and many time steps and I talked to
him about how he made this video and he
said it was very difficult for him
because he had to go and find these
interesting points and to make the video
he had to choose what the camera angle
was and updated every time step he's
also doing interpolation between the
data between each frame because he has
so many time steps and then he has these
he wants to make it smooth so he has all
this he's also this just switched on the
one side from temperature to the
metallicity so like what the composition
of the star is and so he had to update
that and also in time the interesting
point might change right like at time
zero your the interesting point your
data might be located at one point and
at time Z it might be something it might
be at a different point and so we need
interactivity to be able to find this
and so this is what we're trying to do
now with widgets I'm going to move out
of this slide so interactivity allows
for on the PI fly parameter their tuning
so we can adjust our color maps maybe we
can see that like there's an interesting
area but it's a skewed by whatever color
map we have maybe going to change the
scale of it maybe want to change the
view so we are zooming in on that point
or maybe you want to change the width of
the view or something like that but it
also allows for exploration we can find
out all of this interesting
in our data if we have interactivity but
we can't do that if we just have to keep
rerunning the same Python script
changing something a little bit every
time right that can get very annoying
and I think probably all of us have had
to do that at some point in our in our
lives I definitely had to do it and it
reveals the interesting science but also
in separate from ourselves it allows
science to be accessible if we can make
our data interactive and we can allow
people to invest it like explore it
themselves we can do a lot of outreach
right we can make our data accessible to
non-scientists to people who might like
be interested and what the temperature
of a nuclear reactor is at this
particular point right and you can show
them like what the reactivity is or
maybe you want to show them this climate
model and they want to browse and like
look what the temperature in Denmark is
at one point and compare it to what the
temperature in Texas is and so all of
this interactivity is very important and
it allows us to do outreach to
non-scientists but also to those people
who don't identify as hackers there's a
lot of people who don't really enjoy
coding and don't enjoy this very fun
process of adjusting and re running your
Python script every five minutes right
and so it allows you to work with your
collaborators who also might not be as
interested in getting it down into the
nitty-gritty of software development as
you might be and last - those that are
new to the data so maybe you have run
the simulation you're passing on to your
collaborator and they want to explore it
themselves rather than you saying look
at exactly at this point you can give
them the data and they can explore it on
their own if they have the right tools
to do so there's a lot of tools that
already exist in the scientific type of
Python ecosystem that make science more
accessible and I this is just a few of
them and not all of them are scientific
Python but I've tried to focus it on
that and actually I think next month
talk or next weeks is using PI thes
which is right here without the image
but so you can see that this is
something that people care about right
you want to be able to use interactive
tools
so what we want to do with YT is make a
jupiter widget and so how many of you
have heard of or have used jupiter
widgets before great okay so like half
so okay we're gonna do also a brief
introduction of jupiter widgets I'm not
going to dive too deep but you'll kind
of see an example of what they look like
so I want to say also that this is
specifically what I'm going to be
talking about what this interactivity is
specific to YT and using interactivity
with YT all those things I showed on the
previous slide are helpful for
interactivity with other packages and so
if you're really interested in a
different package you can like look
through whatever interactive features
they might have as well so first this is
in the first now I'm just gonna load in
general a bunch of things that are
dependent just to give you an example of
what it looks like to use standard I pie
widgets with YT and see what that looks
like so that's why I have to load all
these things like iPad jets and I PI
data widgets and now I'm going to load a
data set that's in our sample data
called isolated galaxies this is a very
very basic isolated galaxy in space and
so you'll see it's gonna be just
centered at one point and there's
nothing else around it so I'm going to
load that and whitie returns some stuff
telling us about the domain and what it
looks like so what the left edge and the
right edge looks like and whether
there's time if there's a timestamp or
something like that so this next cell is
really big and that's because I'm
building up a couple of different things
to make my visualization interactive
using YT so I have that I have the same
YT load and then I have some trail it's
that I'm setting these are listeners
that you can set that work with I PI
with I PI widgets that you can update
and then you can link them back and
forth as you interact with with as you
interact with the data and then I am
gonna have some observers so I want to
look at my view Center at X&Y so I'm
observing that and if that changes I
have to update my image
and then observe the width which is
corresponding to how far I'm zoomed in
or out and so I have this width listener
with the trail it's observing and the
then I have some unchanged functions
here so what these are doing is if I
notice a change in these I'm triggering
this function to be called so those are
nice little trait lit decorators and
then I have some I'm making some sliders
down here with I pie widgets so that's
what's happening here this is a float
slider with each of the center X Y and
then the width so that's my zoom and
then and then I'm going to return that
in a box and so I'm gonna have these
things that's gonna take a little bit
because it's doing a couple different
things so it's telling me I'm making a
fixed resolution buffer down here and
then I'm gathering a field list and
that's because when we load in this data
YT will detect whatever fields exist so
you might have many different fields
that exist on the mesh that's in defined
in your data so YT can read all of those
in and then it will detect them and so
you can see a field list as you go
through it so this is isolated galaxies
and we can play around with it so this
is my zoom I can zoom in it's kind of
slow you can see there's a major lag
here it's still updating even after I've
stopped dragging
I'm moving x and y and you can see that
there's a lot of lag here and that's
because every time I'm moving through oh
and so now there's I'm getting YT is
telling me it's making this and I over
filled my buffer now so that's why we
know we've filled out the cell but
that's fine and so you can see that that
was actually really slow and that's
because every time we're doing this we
have a lot of data and every time we
trigger one of these events we ask YT to
recalculate the image and then send it
back to us right so what this looks like
so imagine also if instead of being just
on my laptop I have a large data set on
a supercomputer or a remote server that
I'm working with I have my laptop that's
running YT you can see very effective
and I send my request to that server
to generate this new image and then what
the computer or the remote server is
going to do is actually going to
generate the image itself on that side
and then serialize the image and then
send it back to me and then I'm gonna
pull that image back onto my computer
and then my computer will display it
right and so you can imagine as you
trigger each one of these events and you
do this many many times you can have a
lot of lag and you're really dependent
on a lot of different parameters when
you're doing that so one might this
become cumbersome so you have the time
to send the signal to your server you
have the time to serialize and
deserialize the image which can take
quite a bit of time time to calculate
the image and depending on how fine of a
resolution you have that can take some
time also the time to pull it from the
server back to your machine and then
also the time to display it on your
machine and then also you have n
interactions so that's just a single
image right each one of those times so
that's what that like you can do this
hundreds and hundreds of times
as you're going through if you just use
like regular widgets or if you just re
running your script many times right so
what if instead we did something a
little different instead of sending a
request than having our server
recalculate the image every time we
could just send all the data back to our
machine and have our machine our local
machine do all the calculations on its
side rather than sending it back and
forth to the server all the time we can
do that we this is something that you
can do and you can calculate the image
in your browser using a jupiter notebook
and this makes sense if you can make the
time to calculate and display that image
on the client side in your browser less
than the time to generate it on the
server so I've given a kind of pseudo
equation here so we have so we still
have the number of times to generate the
image but we only have the time to
calculate it on the client side that's
the only thing that we have to multiply
that in interactions by on the right
hand side we have to multiply end times
the time generated on the server but
also to keep transferring that image
divided by the data transfer rate and so
we in
it can have a fixed upfront cost where
we have the data the amount of data that
we're sending from the data set and that
data transfer rate and then we only have
to send well we only spend time
recalculating the image on the client
side rather than sending it back and
forth every time right and how might
this happen so as you increase the
number of interactions I've hinted at
this many times like as you have n going
up and up and up eventually you can
eventually you're gonna like have
transferred way more data by just
interacting with your image than you
ever would have had you sent your data
to the browser
you also can increase the amount of
space that the image is taking up so you
can imagine if you have like a 30
terabyte data set it's gonna take a
really long time to like get 30
terabytes of image data sent back to
your computer right that's gonna be like
insane but if you this might I will give
an example in a second but as you
increase the image size for example
you're increasing the amount of timett
the amount of data that the image is
taking up and you might need a fine
resolution to be able to do your
exploration and so as you increase the
data of the image size you also are
making it more important or more helpful
to push to the client you can also
decrease the time that it takes to
generate an image on the client side and
I'll talk a little bit how we address
this using YT widgets so I mentioned
this parameter of like the the data of
the image size right and in the
beginning I talked a little bit about
different types of mesh data that we can
read with YT this is an example of
adaptive mesh data set and this is a
slice through like a cosmological
simulation and you can see that in
certain parts of the simulation you have
a very coarse mesh and then in other
parts you have a finer mesh right so I
can do a match overlay and I can see
what that looks like and you can see
again that there are certain parts we
have a much finer mesh and you can't
even see the like most refined parts of
the mesh right
and so in especially in cases like this
it becomes very helpful to push your
data to the browser because you have you
might have
regions of your data space that are
extremely coarse and that you don't have
to like worry about sending that data
back and forth all the time because you
only have one value for this huge space
right so if you have like a 2,000 by
2,000 image that you're sending back and
forth that might be a hundred by a
hundred right here and you're sending
that single value hundreds and hundreds
of times so you can imagine as you get a
finer and finer refinement you're going
to increase the size of this image and
also make it more and more difficult to
interact with your data without using
some sort of client-side calculations so
I have an example of instead using our
pack our custom package widgets which
does this widgets calculates the image
in the browser instead of doing it on
the server side so this is the same data
set except I'm going to use the widgets
package so before I was using I PI
widgets or I PI data widgets no I PI
widgets and widgets with YT is our
custom widgets package for YT so I'm
going to take a little bit and we have
so also I would like to say that the
widgets package is very proof of concept
and it's very much an early development
so if any of you are interested or think
that there's more features we could add
please come talk to me afterwards
because we really this is like a new
space that we're expanding in in YT so
our first image you don't see much but I
can switch the color scale and I
switched it to log now and I can see the
lower and upper color bar the maps and
stuff like that I mean I can zoom in and
you can see this goes way faster then
when I was working with the standard
widgets before and that's because I have
the entire slice of this data in my
browser right now and I'm using the
browser itself to recalculate the image
so if I want I can change the color map
so I can change its like plasma or
something like that my browser has all
the tools to be able to recalculate that
image and regenerate it with this new
color map
because I pushed that all of that
information all that functionality to
the browser I also so I showed I tried
to be a little transparent up here with
what we're pushing exactly so we have an
X Y and a DX and dy value to say what
the mesh width and stuff are but we also
have so if you have widgets loaded and
you just use display we've overridden
the display function in YT that you
actually automatically get the widget
displayed if you have widgets on so this
is exactly the same one with a slice
through the data set I could also make a
projection so I'm going to integrate I'm
going to make a density projection
through Z with the same data set and we
can see it's gonna look a little bit
smoother than the other one and if i
zoom in we can look at that let's see
what it looks like
I can also so we also have added Mouse
events so I can click in here and it
adjusts everything I can also drag the
image and go really quick so maybe I
like you know I see something
interesting here and I want to zoom in
on it I can recenter it just by clicking
there and zoom in as far as I want okay
so you can see that once you push things
to the browser you can do things a lot
quicker so that's an example of using
widgets so what does this mean like I've
shown you what it kind of looks like and
I've hinted at what we've been doing and
what we're doing is with a single fixed
upper and cost we eliminate the
requirement to transfer all of those
images all we're doing is now we have a
requirement to calculate the number of
images using t client and I'll talk
about in a second how we tried to reduce
T client I mentioned also that this is
useful and some but not all cases if you
have a very refined mesh and the amount
that you're like you know you're not
going to need a ton of interaction
you're not going to do a ton of
perturbations on it it's probably not
going to be necessary for you to be
using widgets at all like you could be
re running your Python script on its own
or maybe you could even be doing it with
using the server because you need the
computing power of the server to be able
to
process through the data right we can
have some stoat we still have some
limitations that widgets can limit for
us so I'm going to talk a little bit
about now what widget does and how we do
this so I mentioned that with widgets
when we're pushing things to the client
side we have to reduce that T client and
we've done that through a series of
different choices that we've made and
I'm going to talk a little bit about
what's happening so we have YT and we
passed all these different values that
you saw in the previous notebook we have
our mesh our P X P Y and then the width
and X&Y and then also the data values
and then we pass this into our widgets
function and I used to be called YT pi
canvas but this is actually the widgets
black box yellow box so you know that's
how you would use it but you're gonna
learn what's inside it rather than
thinking of it as a simple box thing so
we passed that in and we have some
objects that are written in rest that
have been targeted to webassembly
webassembly is very fast and performant
and so that's what's actually doing
these recalculations of the image and so
we pass those values into something
called the fixed resolution buffer
viewer which is one of the sub widgets
in the widgets package and then we have
a variable mesh and the variable mesh is
one of the data structures that exists
in web assembly and then the fixed
resolution buffer is allocated it is
whatever the images we allocate the
image size in the pixels in width and
height so we send so we send that data
into the fixed resolution buffer viewer
so we've allocated it and we've we have
the data in stored in this object called
the variable mesh and we send that data
array then to the normalizer which then
takes that data puts it now based on
this like mesh size whatever that's
supposed to be and sends it to like
reece gives it RGB a values using
whatever color map that you select and
also the scale whether it's linear or
log and then what the min and Max values
are so that way you have the bounds of
your call
map and then the normalizer sends rather
than a data array it sends an image ray
back and that's deposited in the fixed
resolution buffer and then we get a
rendered image and so that's what the
widgets package is doing is we're
sending these things so this is Python
once we pass it in to the widgets
package we have it through we like put
it into JavaScript then this here is web
assembly so it's gone through three
different languages at this point we
have Python JavaScript and then web
assembly and then some of these things
we don't have to like resync like the
web assembly objects and can calculate
on the web assembly objects we don't
have to sync back and forth with
JavaScript unless we need to so how does
it work okay so I just showed you how
the first render works so what happens
when we change the color map so we
change the color map name we have our we
have our normalizer widget which changes
stuff right and so the data array hasn't
changed because the data our view looks
exactly the same so we don't have to
change anything in the date array but
the normalizer then is going to recall
the normalization because it sees that
one of these trait lets the color map
name has changed and it's going to
update the image array and it's going to
update the rendered image and then we're
gonna see a new image in the browser
okay so that's like a simpler one
because we didn't have to we didn't have
to go through everything right we are
just changing stuff in the normalizer if
we do a canvas interaction so let's say
we change let's say we do a zoom then we
change the view width right because we
might have some scale of our view that
we're looking through so we're changing
the view width as a result our fixed
resolution buffer allocation changes
whatever a space we're looking at is
gonna change now because we're looking
at a different point in our data so
that's gonna change and then the data
array is going to change because we're
passing it back into the normalizer so
whatever point of our data whatever data
needs to be normalized is going to need
to change so the normalizer recalculate
set sends a new image array back to the
viewer and then we get a new rendered
image
so I mentioned that we have these
webassembly objects and why did we
choose webassembly so what assembly is
really fast it's much faster than
JavaScript in general but it's been
designed actually to work with
JavaScript it's also like binary and so
we can have all our data stored in web
assembly but not have to sync back and
forth with like JSON objects or
something like that it's a sandbox
memory environment so we have some
safety there and we're as a result we
reduce T client with web assembly and
why did we choose rest so there's many
different programming languages that you
can use and you can compile to web
assembly you can compile the web
assembly with like C or C++ I think but
we chose rest because it was safe
I personally was new to all of these
languages and so I was kind of choosing
which one would be interesting rest is a
really new sort of ecosystem and they're
doing a lot of work in the web assembly
the rest and web assembly sphere and so
that was really interesting to see it's
very performant it's on par with other
really high performance computing
languages and the community itself was
very welcoming to new sort of web
assembly based projects so I want to
kind of mention a little bit about like
how we got the web assembly objects
compiled from rest so on the rest side
we like make art we make our structures
and we define them and so like there's a
lot more to the code but we have these
these sort of decorators at the top of
the structure and so we say this is
something that I want to buy that I want
to be able to access with web assembly
through JavaScript so making this wasum
bind gen like comment at the top and so
then when I target and when I compile it
on the java soap side I get an
automatically compiled JavaScript file
that's made when I target and I make
this web assembly and then I can call
these functions on Java from JavaScript
once I it's compiled
also there's something called wess
impact this is what we use to compile
our rest to webassembly and it's very
easy so we so it takes our rest object
and it compiles then it puts it in a
package environment that we can just
upload straight to NPM and so it makes
it very very easy for us we don't have
to do a ton of work and it also makes it
very accessible and so this is an
example of exactly what I do when I'm
about to do a new release of our of our
our rust to webassembly side of the
widget so I say was--and packin it and
then I have our scope because we release
all our packages within the group lab
and then it compiles everything for me
and then I have a dot pake pkg directory
and that has my webassembly objects in
my java script linking already set up
for me okay so now I have another demo
so I showed you some of our sample data
with isolated galaxies and which is like
a sample data set that we use all the
time we also so you saw that video
before of the pop to prime simulation
which is this formation of this
population to star that was the video
with two images side-by-side so that
data is accessible Britain Smith made
his data available publicly so anybody
can download it so here is an example of
using widgets with pop to prime through
the densest location in the in the data
set and so we we have done the
pre-processing of this to make it a
little easier if you want to play around
with it
also I should say that the first so you
only see the image after I interact with
the widget because the first image
that's created is empty and so it's not
tell you interact with the canvas in
some way that you'll see the first
rendered image it's ok here we go
so here's pop to prime this is a slice
through the data set I think this is
like you know it's not too big but it's
on the order of tens of megabytes and
I'm playing around with this I can
update the limits of the color bar
yeah I want to go I need to go there we
go so I can interact with that I can go
up or down in the slice this is an
adaptive mesh refinement simulation and
so it's going to have several orders of
magnitude of mesh refinement so I'm
going to make a zoom slider our zoom
slider on this one is linear so it's not
going to be super interesting to look at
so now I can play around with this zoom
slider and look at what the what this is
going to look like instead so you can
see that updating I'm going to try and
zoom out a second so maybe you can see
that a little bit yeah okay there we go
there we go so we can like play around
with that a little bit we can also link
because we have all these things set up
as trail it's we could link that so that
was a density figure now I'm going to
link a density and temperature plot
side-by-side okay so on the left is
density on the right is temperature and
I you can see that it's maintained the
density plot well now it updated because
I played it hit it but this kept the
same lower and upper color bar values
from the previous plot because it kept
all of those attributes so now if I
interact with one of these both will
update because I've linked them so this
way you can explore parts of your data
set but still interactively browse based
on multiple fields right which is pretty
cool so that's a slice a projection is
much bigger so this is like 200
megabytes and we're going to do a
projection plot of the same data set and
this is a really long cell but it's
doing everything that I just did in the
previous one so I have my density and my
projection data that I'm passing into
our widget I'm linking the center and
the width and whether the color bar is
log and then I'm making a slider and
then setting some things with the
temperature color map okay here we go
and so this is a little slower again we
still get some slowdown because like as
the data gets bigger it just gets harder
to interact with uh I think I oh I was
playing with the linear scale see not
smart this is the one time time there we
go there we go
so um and so this is like kind of what
Britain was doing when he was looking at
his data as he was looking for
interesting like a very dense part as
the star was being formed and say you
can like zoom in on it you can update
the color map immediately so I could
change this down maybe now I know I'm at
a more interesting part so I can live
update that on the right hand side so
this called these controls are just
controlling one side but because I have
trail it's I can still update this color
map if I want to so the I named this frb
proj t this is the map name which is
inferno I'm gonna change it does anybody
have a favorite terrible color map you
can see how horrible it's gonna look hot
pink hot pink is great man okay well we
can see what jet looks like to start
with okay so there's jet I one of my
favorites is doom which is the color map
from the video game which looks terrible
so that's gonna be great I mean this is
what you should use for all your science
just telling all of you so you can see
still like we still have some
performance things as you get larger and
larger data that you're pushing to the
browser it could still be difficult so
the limitation of the widget so we
haven't done a ton of so because this is
still very proof-of-concept we haven't
done any like memory limiting
calculations we're pulling that entire
data set into our browser and so that is
a limb that is our limitation so like
that was like 200 megabytes that I
pulled straight into my browser so like
is because it's a slice or projection
right if we are not loading the full
three dimensional data set because we're
still only browsing in X or Y and so
that's actually a limitation our widget
only it right now requires just a 2d
data slice you can't browse in 3d if you
do want to browse in 3d then you would
have to do a new selection and then you
have to go back to transferring your
data from the server back to your client
there's a potential limitation for data
sizes so as you can imagine you're
limited by whatever memory you have on
your machine and so we have we have some
limitations with whatever we're doing
however this is a very large data set
the original thing is like I think like
each one each time step was something
like 200 gigabytes and so a projection
is 200 megabytes so we order that we
reduce that by an order of magnitude or
more than an order of magnitude now I'm
like second-guessing myself yes yeah
no ok so I I will get to questions at
the end I know I'm really excited that
you're into it there's limited
functionality you saw we can update the
color map and we can drag and drop and
stuff but we still don't have like a ton
of functionality like we can't you know
select data and like make a new plot
from our data selection or anything yet
it's a very very proof-of-concept and it
requires maintenance and multiple
package ecosystems and languages we have
to manage stuff and rest we have to
manage stuff in JavaScript because I buy
widgets are based on JavaScript we had
to write a lot more JavaScript than you
normally would have to with a widget and
we also have to manage stuff with Python
and it's still early in development and
so like as a result it's going to be
buggy and I put in the last one the
tools are new so like the rest and web
assembly group is very good but it's
still like their stuff is also limited
because they're actively developing all
of these packages as well so moving
forward we'd like to broaden the
functionality of the widget and I'm
happy to talk to you about this because
I know I'm running out of time and so
I'm happy to talk to any of you about
like where we want to go with it and if
you have any suggestions in particular I
want to highlight we want to make it
reproducible so like you can browse
around in this but it would be very hard
to know exactly where you were unless
you knew all the trait objects that
we've implemented so we'd like to make
something that returns all these values
to you it's that way you can say I
browsed in our data this is where I got
and then you can send it to your
collaborator so then they can make that
exact state and reproduce it on their
machine there here's some links and so I
will give you the link to the slides in
a second but all of these are helpful
links if you're interested in developing
a widget like this on your own the rest
whitie tools is our web arrests to web
assembly package that is outside of the
main widgets release this is like an
assistant package that we've built with
that works with the widgets so then the
widgets repository is second the data in
the paper for the pop to prime data set
is this one so this is britain stuff
these are the filter data that we made
to do this
to do the example that I just showed you
so the Jew so if you want to play around
with these and you don't feel like
installing a Python environment or maybe
you're still lukewarm about widgets and
you just want to look at them we have
this link here is gonna bring you to
like a launch pad that will make a
jupiter notebook in a isolated
environment for you that you can play
around with the widgets exactly what the
data that I just showed you and so then
there's some other stuff about rest and
webassembly and stuff like that you can
install the widget with pip install and
I'd like to thank especially Patricia
and Shawn law for bringing me out here
also Matt and the YT developers because
it's like an amazing package I'm still
learning stuff about it every day and
I'm like amazed at some of the stuff
that it can do and these people here are
people who helped me with the data or
making the data or generating some of
the images so nathan goldbam did the
galaxy simulation Kasper made the launch
pad for the jupiter notebooks on the
last slide
Sam Wolcott made the date the MRI data
and Britton Smith did the population to
something we're always looking for new
users and collaborators so please come
talk to me if you feel like it and with
that I would be happy to take any
questions
oh and also this first link here the
monkey met hub I Oh or add slash 2019
3:13 pi data is a link to the slides so
you can play around with that all of
those slides have links to various
projects and stuff like that so feel
free I've tried to make it a good
resource for you if you're interested in
any of this thank you
[Applause]
community and the whitee development
community oh yes okay okay great so
Patricia asked me to describe the
development community how many people
are actively contributing to the project
and can I also describe what an open
pull request is because I kind of like
skimmed over that a little bit about the
CF compliant data so the whitee project
has over a hundred and fifty like it's
one hundred and twenty-six contributors
of overall time there's several active
developers I don't know in that number
offhand but we can look at the github
activity if we want to maybe afterwards
in my group at NCSA there are at least
four people who are actively developing
whitey and that are part of the whitey
project in the organization overall and
so that's all the whitey related stuff
and I can mention okay so the pull
request is so our stuff is all hosted on
github I mentioned there's a link to the
repo when I first did the brief
introduction to whitey and so any of you
could contribute to whitey if you want
to so if you like have some you know if
you have like a regular mesh structure
it's gonna be very easy for you to build
this custom front-end because you can
copy one that exists from a different
regular mesh that already exists and so
when you so when we have new people who
are interested in the data they can
contribute all whatever code that they
want to back up stream into the main
whitey project repository and they do
that via a pull request and so what you
say is you request that the main package
that you have cloned you're requesting
that they pull your your data or your
code into their repository not data
whatever code you've developed and so
usually there's some limitations so we
have some contributing guidelines and
most open-source projects do and our
contributor guidelines ask people that
you know if you build a new feature
please add tests this is what our test
package look like
an example of documentation and so we
have this is why we have like a pretty
large set of documentation based on some
of these different front ends and stuff
like that oh okay yes okay good
see I like have realized that I have now
yeah bias here an open pull request
means that somebody has submitted code
but it hasn't been accepted into the
repository yet so like maybe they still
have a feature that they're fixing maybe
the community has identified a bug or
maybe they've submitted it as a work in
progress so I have a I have an open pull
request for a nuclear engineering
simulation code called de novo and
that's the thing I used for my
dissertation data to transport radiation
through space and so I submitted what's
called a work in progress pull request I
said this is a work in progress but I'd
like you to look at it so that way I can
fix things before you know it's too late
like if you're kind of you're at a key
point then you need feedback from the
developers this is very helpful if you
have a very distributed developer base
which we do in the whitee project yeah
um no but however oh yes all right so
the question was is there any existing
work to use Jeep to leverage GPUs to do
this and no however we do have a volume
rendering like an interactive volume
rendering thing that whitey works with
that I didn't really cover but I briefly
mentioned exists and I believe that uses
some GPU stuff but I'm not positive
because I haven't worked on that at all
but um yeah no we're not working on
using GPUs no no it is a reference to a
Neil Stevenson novel character and so my
P I is gonna be very upset with me but I
don't know exactly which book but the
character is named whitey
does anybody know oh whoa okay well then
I'm not the only one here do you know oh
okay sorry
ooh yeah so the question is what's the
difference between a strop I and whitey
so I'm not a big user of a strop I I'm
not like an astrophysicist but I think
my the idea that I get is that a strop
I'm supposed to do a lot more data
processing than whitey and it's not
meant for visualization in the same way
but I could I don't want to weigh in on
that because I don't know enough about a
strop I too like definitively say
something about that one thing that your
question has reminded me of though and
that I may be briefly mentioned is Olive
so whitey is meant to work in the
scientific Python ecosystem so Astro PI
and whitey developers work together on a
lot of features because we want the
packages to be compatible you know we
don't see working in the scientific
Python ecosystem is a competition but as
a collaboration and so whitey has some
core scientific Python dependencies like
numpy and matplotlib and we would not be
able to work
the package that we do without those
projects and so I think that Astro pie
has a lot of features that are very
complementary to IT and yeah so like
matplotlib I mentioned before like all
of our plots are actually matplotlib
under the hood and so you can customize
them the same way you would with a
matplotlib plot so if you want if you
know how to annotate matplotlib figures
you can do that with a whitey figure
because under the hood it is matplotlib
yeah so that's difficult I mean this is
like something that we have to be very
cognizant of as we're developing out
widgets in particular and it's a
challenge I think what we try to do our
general practice is to try and have all
the performance parts of the code in
webassembly and to not pass large data
objects in and out of webassembly
we just have the upfront cost of passing
the data the full data into the web
assembly variable math object and then
that lives there and we might call like
something like the view center or some
very small single number to update the
view but we're not passing the full data
back out of web assembly unless we're
making a new image just of that
particular data and so we try to keep
all the performant things in webassembly
we also because we're interacting so
much with web assembly we have to build
out more JavaScript functionalities all
those mouse clicks and stuff we're done
using javascript we're not really
interacting with python with those and
so as a result our widget is not as
Python heavy as many other widgets are
that have been built using I PI widgets
No No
so we have tried to avoid that and so
yeah we don't have like a ton of
parallel stuff
however if if you were using just
standard I PI widgets with YT like in my
first example then YT would be doing
some of that serialization for you but
we're not doing that because we pass the
raw data into the web assembly objects
so like there is some parallel there but
it's not being used by the same use case
right like if you're if you're making a
single figure in a Jupiter notebook and
you don't use widgets then you'd be
using the YT functionality but if you're
using widgets then you're using that
code and they might look similar sort of
under the hood but they're based on a
different use case and so you're not
using them at the same time yeah that's
a great question yeah
[Music]
[Applause]